هنا في منطقه النصيرات تحديدا منطقه
بلوكسي او المنطقه الرئيسيه المدخل
الرئيسي لمخيم النصيرات استهدفت طائرات
الاستطلاع هذه السياره ويعني وخلف هذه
السياره هو مبنى سكني مدخل الصيرات دمار
كبير وهائل في هذه المنطقه بعد استهداف
المقاتلات الحربيه ويصعب دخول اي شخص لهذه
المنطقه بسبب ان الاحتلال تحدث عبر
منشوراتها انها منطقه خطره ومنطقه قتال هي
اغلب المباني والبنيه التحتيه في ه
المنطقه على مدخل رات تقريبا مدمره تقريبا
ه مخبز الياسين اللي كان
بيخدم
اي سكان ومواطنين نصرات مدمر بشكل كامل
الابنيه والعمارات اللي على صلاح الدين
برضه اغلبها مدمر بشكل كامل
اي زي ما نحن شايفين دمار كامل يعني في
المكان مخبز ياسين الذي تم تدميره بشكل
كامل وعماره ياسين هذه العماره مكونه يعني
من عده طوابق وعدد من الشقق السكنيه ه
الاحتلال دمر المنطقه بشكل كامل استهدف كل
شيء في هذه المنطقه يعني لربما اشبه ب
الزلزال ضرب هذه المنطقه منطقه مدخل مخيم
النصيرات رموا مناشير علينا انه اخذوا
المكان في المكان هذا فخلينا المكان
وتوجهنا لدخل الصراط للمنطقه الامنه زي ما
حكوا اليهود وطلعنا هيك رجعنا الصبحيات ما
لقينا كل البيت مدمر على بكره ابيه يعني
تسع صواريخ في 16 ضاربينهم غير العماره
الثانيه يعني العماره اللي فيها المطعم
الملكي هذه العماره برضه لنا ب فضل الله
برضه
دمروها خلوها ركام وقعت على البنك من كثر
ما ضربوها صواريخ هدول بيهدم يعني مش
الهدف مقاومه وغير مقاومه لا الهدف قتل
الناس هدم البيوت ما لا هدف مقاومه ولا
غير مقاومه فيها المقاومه هنا هدف قتل
العباد بس قتل الناس وهدم المنشات العامه
هذه النقطه الاخيره التي وصلت لها اليات
الاحتلال هنا في منطقه النصيرات هذا هو
مفترق شارع المحكمه الشارع المحكمه القديم
دمار كبير في هذه المنطقه وهذه المنطقه
التي تحدث الاحتلال بانها منطقه
خطره نعم الان طائرات الاحتلال قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه قصفت هدف لربما سنتعرف
على هذا الهدف في هذه المنطقه نعم صاروخ
اخر صاروخ اخر من قبل طائرات الاحتلال
الحربيه في هذه
اللحظات يعني بالقرب من مدخل مخيم
النصيرات
هذه المنطقه خلف
المصنع نعم الجهه الجنوبيه ل مدخل مخيم
النصيرات قد قصفت المقاتلات
الحربيه
منزلا في هذا المكان